on peut dire quand même que bon vous
raconter à la fois une aventure qui a
duré trois mois
une aventure homosexuelle qui a duré
trois mois j'essayais disons le disons
le camp même nom ce n'est pas parce que
sinon j'ai pas lu le bouquin et que vous
racontez il ya le récits s'entrecroisent
avec le récit d'un inceste mais on peut
dire ça quand même
oui enfin c'est 100 m -cd si tu sors de
deux mots de dire de rester des trucs
comme ça fait mais on va pas revenir sur
tout ce que sinon ce serait trop mesquin
mais oui il ya effectivement un moment
une association qui est faite entre le
terme d'inceste et entre le terme
d'homosexualité et puis non elle au
milieu qu'est la wii
la fête de noël voilà donc c'est vrai
que ça ça ça vient se rencontrer
l'inceste l'homosexualité dans ce livre
en fait quand on lit le bouquin on se
demande d'abord si c'est de la fiction
si c'est de l'auto fiction si c'est du
témoignage on sait rien en fait c'est ce
qui fait le charme du livre en plus je
vous le concède mais aisément dominé
lors du témoignage ça alors là vous vous
doutez bien que c'est la dernière chose
qu'ils puissent enfin non quoique
vraiment non parce que sinon c'est pas
possible
parce que c'est pas possible à ce que
s'il n'avait pas d'écrivain un écrivain
c'est pas un témoin de rien du tout
c'est juste un écrivain quand on voit
une fille dans le bouquin qui s'appelle
comme vous qui est voué qui avoue ce que
vous allez skate avoué dans ce bouquin
la première question à se poser c'est
est-ce que ces vécus ou pas mais ça
c'est pas la question n'est pas là la
question c'est à dire que c'est de la
littérature ses troupes puisque vous
êtes venu en fait à l'émission de
peut-être si je peux me permettre de
voilà c'était de dark est ce que vous
auriez à nous dire de solutions pour
faire et c'est même pas si je vais me
rendre mais écoutez c'est très simple
tout à l'heure en attendant je me disais
mais qu'est ce que c'est ce livre je ne
sais je ne bosse je sais pas et je
disais je disais aux personnes qui m'ont
accompagné je disais mais c'est pas
compliqué je vais m'appuyer sur les
questions qui va me poser je vais bien
me poser des questions donc je m'appuie
sur les questions qui me pose pas de
questions je m'appuie sur les questions
qui me posent
voilà c'est la meilleure chose à faire
parce que sinon qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est du discours qui peut être
politique ou qui peut être littéraire et
d'un coup on dit moi j'ai un truc à
balancer je le balance
bon voila mon livre c'est tac tac tac le
valence faut que je fasse passer ce
message
il n'y a pas de message il ya une seule
chose possible à mon avis si
effectivement vient à la radio à la
télévision n'importe où c'est de voir ce
que la personne qui peut poser une
question ou une autre personne peut
envoyer
est ce qu'on peut voilà à partir de là
ce qui peut être communiquée quelque
chose quand même dans ce que vous avez
écrit à la communication l'écriture
c'est pas la faute des données alors
quelque chose à de données oui mais
voilà ça m'a fait du mal à le formuler
la question vous trouvez que je formule
pas bien bien
ccc mille tandis que vous êtes une sorte
de rigueur alors ici de francs très
précis sur exactement ce que vous avez
envie de dire qu'elle est précise mais
je n'ai rien envie de dire ces pressions
tarifaires pour moi n'aurait pas dû rien
dire mais c'est ça il faut surfer
l'intérieur de briser des algériens et à
rien y'a rien le silence et organes à
huy est la risée à mai pour briser le
silence
il ne faut rien dire voilà il faut pas
les mettre ou pas alors je alors
qu'effectivement si l'âge de 26 ans va
être page 26 nous sommes attendait il
m'a demandé un truc intéressant
moi il m'a demandé si je pensais écrire
un autre livre
oui je sais tout juste tradition un jeu
positivement huitième livre je n'ai
jamais dit que c'était le premier je
pense que vous verrez bien
dix ans ensemble
y en a déjà qui est en train de s'écrire
emmène sur moi ça me dérange pas que
vous réagissiez comme ça moi j'ai invité
souvent eric et ramzy dans l'émission
c'est pareil je sais pas qui c'est on ne
sait pas bien alors nom vous dit page 26
parce que c'est là où quand il ya des
questions que nous votre livre soulève
encore de la qualité du texte la qualité
du caire dix pages 26 moi-même à 14
heures je vais devenir écrivain je
voulais démarrer très fort
j'ai pensé à l'inceste j'ai séduit mon
père donc voilà je veux dire c'est on se
demande pour ça qu'on se demande on se
dit est ce que c'est dû à ça moi je le
demande est ce que c'est de la création
littéraire est ce que ta réalité cette
fois question alors du marketing
est ce que si on veut vendre vraiment
quelque chose pourquoi pas alors
finalement peut-être que de vivre là ça
c'est une bonne méthode de marketing
oui ça c'est une vraie question qui se
pose déjà la pause oui alors je la
propose on la pose et la cus besoin là
il est rare d'avoir dans un bouquin
quelqu'un qui dit moi j'ai cependant
bourse est censée de l'humour d'inceste
non sérieux c'est pas pour vous
peut-être mais pas de cette chaude
puisque monfils est pour nous les
monarchistes
c'est de l'humour c'est cette phrase
c'est ça peut ça peut être de l'humour
disons que c'est si vous voulez c'est
simplement cette phrase là c'est si je
me dis je me dis ben voila je vais dire
ça comme ça ils ne diront pas me le dise
mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai que c'est on peut se poser la
question aussi de ces effectivement de
de l'argent quoi du business à l'arrêt
ce qui est fait autour d'un thème sont
eux qui n'en ont peut pas se la poser
franchement peut pas se la poser quand
cela pose que des gens cela podium que
les gens je pense qu'ils ont ça en dit
long sur les gens mais franchement vise
votre imaginer une seconde qu'une qu'une
fille qui a 14 ans va se dire tiens
super plan je vais séduire mon père et
puis vint après j'écrirai un livre ça
s'appellera l'inceste et ça se vend se
vendre à 50000 exemplaires si mon
éditeur fait bien son travail le fait
bien il le fait parce qu'il a un livre
qui lui permet de le faire bon mais
cette phase cette phrase est drôle moi
je je trouve que c'est tous les soirs
des autres jeunes réflexes et une
réplique abusant de ce qu'ils ont envie
d'un terrible
moi je sais que je vais vous dire une
phase de gym s'assure alors par exemple
je fais un peu de marketing la gallésie
d'inscription cunnilingus ps 27
formidable passage ça je vous laisse le
découvrir dans le livre page 64 jeu
léché mois quand vous êtes avec la file
jeu léché moi cette mère dont l'enfant
est une chienne allait bien sa frappe et
bien soit je suis folle vraiment folle
je ne toucherai qu'un petit public de
détraqués dans mon genre si je continue
je suis un public de détraqués mon petit
public de détraqués c'est ma bouée voilà
et vous savez il ya rien j'ai reçu parmi
les lettres que je j'ai reçu ces
derniers temps je reçus une lettre
absolument magnifique qu'il n'y avait
pas du tout de la drees et téléphonie
rien pour que je réponde et où il y
avait juste marquer donc où la phrase
c'était mon petit public les traquer ces
mabhouh est là dans le livre celle que
vous avez cités et la personne qui me
répond m'envoie sur une lettre juste
comme ça
christine je suis un morceau de votre
bouée assez bien ah bah c'est super
c'est super y'a pas l'adresse j'ai rien
à votre petit public de détraqués quand
même ça fait quoi à 50000 personnes à
bord au moment qu'ils ont achetés non
bien beaucoup détraqué voix persée
draguer
oui nous et ces petites annick alors je
vais pas je vais pas dire tout le
bouquin mais en face c'est vrai que il
ya cette relation donc par téléphone ils
rament page 206 là quand même
c'est violent allez-y son père l'a forcé
à manger des clémentines sur son sexe
ses l'inceste
il l'a sodomisée seulement après il
allait à la pharmacie acheter de la
vaseline et je voudrais savoir parce
qu'il fait rire david avec clémentine
célarié
c'est parce qu'elle s'appelle clementi
gens ont ri parce que je pensais que
penser à moi parce que je m'appelle fait
mentir il est bien d'accord et oui mais
voyez mais son père d'avancé à manger
des clémentines sur son sexe vous êtes
marais non je me suis marié parce que
j'ai entendu des gens rigolaient parce
que je me suis dit tiens il en parlait
déjà plus continue voilà donc c'est vrai
que on rigole des fois souvent de choses
qu'on ne comprend pas c'est vrai non
mais c'est un sujet quand même délai
vous terminez alors pas non c'est pas
vrai mais c'est page 202 ces quatre
pages avant l'inceste est vraiment le
livre où je me présente comme une grosse
merde tout écrivain doit le faire au
moins une fois dans sa vie après on
verra
désir quest
après peut-être que c'est pas ça veut
dire bon déjà si vous lisez jusqu'à la
fin du paragraphe il ya quelque chose
qui dément immédiatement ça parce que ça
sert à rien de dire des choses si on est
dément pas après parce que les choses
sont jamais comme ça rigoureuse et est
vrai qu'en soient les opinions ça existe
pas encore votre votre éditeur jean marc
roberts se dit en parlant de vous bien
entendu elles veulent être célèbre
christine et j'ai tellement envie
qu'elle le soit vraiment vidé deux
célèbres lui il a envie c'est normal
c'est votre éditeur parce que bon on
sait bien que l'éditeur
quand l'auteur touche 10 francs ayant
tous 90 mais vous vous avez vraiment
envie d'être c'est même moi j'ai envie
depuis que j'écris fin ça fait ça fait
15 ans et puis depuis mon premier livre
qui est sorti à dix ans j'ai envie de
pouvoir continuer à écrire et j'ai envie
que de surnager
j'ai envie que cette bouée là elles me
permettent de surnager et donc qui est
intéressant dans l'histoire de la
célébrité c'est que c'est qu'on n'est
pas tout seul vraiment et qui est 150
lecteurs ou qu'ils en aient 50000 mais
ça change énormément les choses
énormément s'est agrandi la boue et
s'agrandit la boue et ça fait que ben
que même si vous dites exactement les
mêmes choses qu'avant ont fait au moins
semblant de vous écouter
donc bon part qu'il serait dans un
bistrot tous les deux soirs je
l'écouterai aussi parce que vous êtes
assez rare non assise
- depuis modiano j'avais pas vu un
auteur qui comme ça dont j'avais du mal
à saisir les choses et autres sont assez
faciles à elle vous dit souvent non non
et non 10 secondes pour ça non les gens
qui disent non mais moi je modiano ça
peut que me faire plaisir j'aime
beaucoup
depuis que vous êtes arrivé sur le
plateau vous n'avez pas sourit même ri
une seule fois ci qu'est ce qui vous
fait rêver
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire on vous
sent tout le monde en penser les
missions qui me fait rêver
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux